théo vous étiez vous avez été le 2
février 2007 interpellés par des
policiers à aulnay sous bois au
commissariat l'un des fonctionnaires
réaliste que vous êtes grièvement blessé
et vous est transféré à l'hôpital théo
vous expliquez que l'un des policiers
vous aurait violé avec sa matraque sans
suite de nombreux épisodes judiciaires
et de nombreuses manifestations qui se
tiendront pour protester contre les
violences policières avant d'en parler
avec vous on vous a préparé un petit
récapitulatif est ce que vous
connaissiez les taux des oat connaissez
le jeu pour la police nationale dans les
banlieues vous allez vous en parlez
aussi dans un instant regarde en février
2010 est à aulnay-sous-bois théodore
luhaka 22 ans un jeune éducateur de
banlieue sans histoire sur nos météo est
interpellé dans le quartier de la rose
des vents
alors qu'il se rend chez sa soeur il
croise des amis à lui en train de se
faire contrôler par la police décide
d'aller voir ce qu'il se passe et c'est
là que les versions divergent
théo explique qu'il aurait pris la
défense d'un de ses amis qui se serait
pris une grosse gifle par un policier
sans raison le policier de son côté
prétend que théo était venu défendre un
de ses amis dealers qui étaient en cours
d'interpellation en donnant un coup de
poing un policier en quelques instants
tout dégénère théo est encerclée par des
policiers dans la confusion générale son
pantalon est baissé et il aurait été
victime d'un viol avec une matraque
enfin devant l'ambassade pour travaux
qui m'a fait ça le jeune homme se
retrouve à l'hôpital ils accusent les
policiers de viol d'insultés racistes et
d'avoir pris des photos humiliantes de
lui sur snap chatte la france se lève
alors contre les violences policières l'
affaire fait grand bruit
cinq jours après l'incident le président
françois hollande se rend même à
l'hôpital où nous avons aussi
on sait qu'on fait un jeu avait toujours
été connue pour un comportement
exemplaire dans toute la france des
manifestations de soutien à théo au lieu
un an et demi plus tard la sphère n'est
toujours pas réglée et encore
aujourd'hui théaux souffre toujours des
séquelles de cette intervention une
affaire épineuse qui une fois encore
montre l'extrême tension qui règne entre
les forces de l'ordre et certains
habitants de la banlieue
alors théo est avec nous ce soir merci
d'être là déjà été aux mains tousser
merci beaucoup à leur t on vous avez
donc été au centre de l'actualité avec
avec cette affaire il ya un an et demi
on ne parlait que de vous déjà comment
vous avez vécu cette affaire et dans
quel état vous sentez aujourd'hui
bon après quand j'ai vu qu'elle va faire
concrètement à moi j'étais plus en train
de souffrir que nous la faire et voilà
ça fait très mal
vous avez souffert physiquement
physiquement moralement mentalement tu
as et ça c'est le sait le micro qui
souffre la rédac on va on peut on peut
mettre le micro dont on est rendu en
direct
merci c'est arnaud tsamère qui va vous
mettre le micro vous inquiétez pas
s'occupe du sont également ici donc théo
attendait théo parce qu on vous entend
pas mais c'est voilà c'est donc vous
vous connaissiez vous connaissiez le
local théo on connaît la fatigue et tous
les policiers connaissent la ferté au
qu'est ce que vous dites voilà passé par
nantes la haye pour vous est-ce qu'il ya
eu un manquement au niveau douala de
l'interpellation est ce qu'il ya eu une
bavure au niveau de l'interpellation t
ou bien pour vous non vous attendez vous
attendez là parce que je crois que c'est
actuellement une instruction qui en
qu'une instruction était la solution qui
encourt donc ce qu'on veut pas commenter
l'instruction qu'ils encourent et aller
au delà de ça c'est ça nous a interdit
oui par contre là comme tout le monde on
peut voir ce qui a été diffusé dans les
médias on peut avoir la première version
de théo qui n'est pas du tout la même
que celle qu'on découvre sur la vidéo à
l'instant et pendant ce temps là on voit
que nos collègues ont été jetés en
pâture
on a des connexions étaient menacés de
mort de la scène de viol leurs familles
des enfants à cause de cette affaire
théo et puis au final on se rend compte
que c'est énorme souffle et en fait
retombe d'un coup et que les collègues
sont toujours aujourd'hui suspendu dans
la mouise et a personne pour les
défendre parce que françois hollande est
allé au chevet de monsieur t oh oui donc
au moment et à mieux au chevet de théo
les policiers de la france entière ont
vécu ça comme une trahison profane oui
oui ils ont roulé à françois hollande ou
une enveloppe concernant parce que
françois hollande cgem les places au
chevet d'un policier
ouais il s'est déplacé aux cheveux de de
théo donc tant mieux pour théo mais du
paysage on se sont assis de police
là on a le représentant en chef de
l'état qui condamne ni plus ni moins
fameux wii qui condamne sa police
il ya une instruction cours vous êtes
réveillé par le cadre de la commission
rogatoire
il ya un secret d'instruction ça fait
partie de la définition d'une commission
rogatoire
c'est le secret de l'instruction vous
avez décidé de parler de dire ce que
vous avez ou pas subi je suis pas là
pour juger ce qui s'est passé par contre
entre conte parti il ya eu aucune
réponse de la police nationale on a
interdit à mes collègues
de prendre la parole on interdira aux
collègues qui sont intervenus etc
je vous donne je vous donne je vous
donne moi la vérité de ses percées en
amont on n'a pas le droit de répondre
aux attaques on a respecté l'instruction
voulu alors t'es ok ce qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça tout d'abord nous
aussi on a reçu des menaces de mort de
la part des ouïes aller au cinéma de la
barre me rami aussi et boîtes aux
lettres de la part de l'apport des
anonymes à son courage et qu'anime
d'ailleurs avez vous déposé plainte
maintenant reste devant mais non parce
que nous la fait pas bon pour toutes les
menaces de mort que des recenseurs votre
site internet mes collègues ont déposé
plainte
c'est malheureusement à métro dont on a
dit c'est maintenant au delà de ça ce
genre comment ça s'est passé des
policiers nous savons une chose pas les
mots les policiers confond tout le monde
aucun ivoirien me disant 10.10 l'on va
dire comme ceux nés 47 pour ses quarante
cinq 45 dire moi si vous êtes 45 70 ans
que gilles carrez a pas de différences
qui font pas de différence moi je
voulais c'était parce qu'il montre la
journée et comme par hasard quand je
vais déposer les chaussures de ma soeur
oui c'est vraiment que ça tourne donc
vous vous n'aviez rien fait vous étiez
là par hasard pour cent des six mois à
peine
et vous pensez que faisait partie d'un
groupe voilà la vidéo qui va nous sortir
vous font croire que j'ai vus par
l'escalier alors qu'en fait il fait tout
haut du balcon on est là dès là le mont
rose est il écrit ces prêts mois qu'on
est dit mentalement j'ai souffert
physiquement on a souffert mais aussi a
souffert
moi je dis aujourd'hui nature pas qui
paierait à l'épaule et c'est que
soi-disant son soi disant menacé de mort
et où on demanda aux prunes service soit
disant ils sont ils sont pas bien les
policiers qui ont été violents commis
l'attaqué
ça veut dire que ce qu'ils m'ont fait
pour eux c'est pas grave m'a fait bosser
bosser au calme ou qu'ils ont décidé de
demander à un point de service vous en
souffrez aujourd'hui j'en souffre encore
et il reçoit sur mon avis non
voilà même physiquement je suis toujours
prête à me faire du sport c'est plus
rare de ma vie vraiment un bras du tout
parce que les policiers ont confondu
tout le monde comme par hasard comme
souvent il arrive en haut lieu pour
retourner leur tonus et dévoyé c'était
la première fois que vous avez à faire à
les revoir et revoir la police et
apparemment elle est plus et qui m'ont
fait ça de réputation ils ont fait ça
plus la personne ne m'a marqué parce que
ces personnes angie tu si je vais porter
plainte comme moi je suis comme ça
il s'agit de policiers quand comment
elle ça mais je serais pas crédible
vous faites quoi dans la vidéo à la base
était un jeu au foot et j'étais
animateur de quartier à mes enfants des
rues d'accord alors